[Music]
how's it going bros my name is beautiful
welcome back to freakin bookshelf start
to kill me never naked ladies and arms
and stuff
alright good oh yeah I remember like
she's there's a secret item here hey
that's kind of creepy with a hands looks
like he's eating
I must nom nom the item nom nom or she
throw it off maybe that's kind of
disgusting though okay turn up family
picture I find it it's okay I will
probably find this later anyway
you need all the items to unlock the
last part and the last pot no more
titties I knew it
you need that all the items too
[ __ ] is going on here seriously though
what are you doing with your today's I
said that many times and he's on this
game what the [ __ ]
alright let's check the drawers or
something I don't I don't precious can I
please check the drawers please no can't
do [ __ ] make sounds alright I'm
running out of battery lights Lester
there's more boobies goddamn it
okay I think we're in trouble okay Oh
boobies goddamn it
alright let's just go back hey maybe
there's something here I didn't check
this alright
yay yeah yeah I like that yeah
what's wrong with working hands is
popping out anyway I need to find a key
yeah I don't know what the key is
you're telling me mr. naked woman you
tell me what is the clearing you just
want me to look at your puppies okay ah
okay let's go back
nothing there obviously I hear that this
evening no it's a diss again I don't
trust this there's got to be something
there
I mean I we went everywhere I remember
right right okay
all night dad Justin freaked me out
again
there's a lamp oh no its torso again all
right I think we missed the key part but
that just my intuition and I don't have
a very good entry I don't remember how
the key look like I don't like this
place at night and like that ah no she's
no why do they have to block when I'm
going why can't you just let me pass
please woman please I know you're naked
but I need to go ahead please look at
the feet in the background looks like it
has a bunny bunny hat all right nothing
nothin I though that all right we need
to get the [ __ ] out
[Music]
I said you get okay let's go back it's
not not period for today I think I know
why we see through anyway I mean eyes
it's a scam no naked women all right the
odd yeah we're looking at there we've
been in the ladies bathroom and stuff
like ice from now we need to go to
elevator huh there's a power switch
let's go I am so fun I don't know
there's good cats uh I usually like cute
cats I'm sorry if I say I don't like you
but in horror games kit cats [ __ ] is he
doing he's like ye you sure not pass
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah or more like therap or
something hey what the [ __ ] all right we
need to check this out let's do this
save stain oh there's nothing here
there's nothing nothing
oh hey there's Joey alright let's check
it out it doesn't have a door handle all
right I am NOT an expert on how you open
doors without I think I will wait for
that one all right let's just keep on
Charlie
all right how do we get server um paint
and stuff I love paint oh this is
beautiful
look at it off work Jesus guy says oh I
know I will have to clean this god damn
it
oh no it's everywhere I'll get the damn
it hey I'm direction here's our room all
right
something come through the elevator
that's good that's good because you know
things where elevators shouldn't be
working when it's night so that's normal
I mean when in there electricity as out
alright that's cool that's cool huh girl
I mean boy alright what do you want
[ __ ] kid to get that [ __ ] kid
together alright let's open this it's
open opens no all right fine I don't
need key to catch I just need hey what
is this
oh I know I know what it is okay Belmar
all right it's cold up I know there's a
battery here somewhere
come on Barbara cigarette to smoke
I remember this play there's period on
ice is coffee spilling period coffee cup
here all right
I suspect that alkaline I mind battery
phone oh my god it's from digital ink
[ __ ] I bet you were like what kind of
batteries that oh did you Johnny oh my
god I don't want to talk about and you I
need a drink
real bad why are you working out there
on batteries I shouldn't be running
batteries I'm just saying makes no sense
they are haunted I get it all right by
now we should have collected all parts
of the key but we haven't really done
that so we need two more
now we need two more things for the key
and that mean I don't have to cheat it's
fun you're
something all right be right back all
right there you are my dear little penis
yes come to Papa
yes yes yeah almost and I
all right we have [ __ ] daddy wait
what's going on here
oh yeah why am i pointing my flashlight
at her that sounds not good
Oh brah
Oh bro I'll bra bra bra I wanna go there
I have to go there
hello lady lady [ __ ] that
I'm going over here I'll like a copying
machine a lot of fun today print my but
let's just get my butt on this and how
does it work at the illiteracy
Hey all right I got my butt let me see
my butt prints oh there he comes
can't really see what it is that looks
more like a face in my butt I guys have
a nice shape with my butt
all right there you uh might be a
default vagina come here you're bloody
beautiful thing all right then we girls
to mother-effin pieces all right finally
oh my god this game is a [ __ ] I have
all that you see how the key there it
says no people and I'm like [ __ ] that
I'm gonna go anyway
nine to six I knew that cuz I'm the boss
and that's what found now I don't trust
how you're not allowed to be here
neither am i but I'm here anyway
you and I could be friends oh no the
background though I started being in the
way again
all right whatever let's just click this
on switch maybe something good will
happen
hey turn green that's good that's all my
goodness things to him that's badness I
don't know that's on my bad list I don't
know
oh no please don't be behind me and the
hairs in front of me how can a job go
bro bro bro bro it's time shower running
right yes oh the foot all right we got
indicated running I'm out here yep she's
gone ads no problem
going on it a ton trustees
whatever I'm just gonna go [ __ ] [ __ ]
this place I don't need this job anymore
the salad is awful it's not worth it
Jesus Christ I'm just gonna keep on
drawing that's right keep on trolling
that's what my mom Wallace a pity if
anything just keep on trolling oh no I
don't know she didn't tell me anything
about this [ __ ] oh oh oh
that doors not supposed to go friend
that no what's she doing oh oh I hate
which works like that
Hey okay it's gone
let's go it's not ball problem it's
solid it's [ __ ] probably a drum from
Road like a [ __ ] okay
every day lately baby baby hey baby
oh holy [ __ ] I made ha I'm alive I'm
alive it's America oh my lord
I want to thank I want to thank Ono
what's going on here I was going to
thank so many people I'll go get the
exit no I'm good what a safe
wait really Oh Oh No
oh my goodness get out on Facebook you
later later yeah I don't want to kiss
yeah this ghost thing
ah a visa glad yes yes
although and that I do I already knew
this already knew that come up with new
material girl now that you possess of
course don't flatten all right we don't
have all the items for the last part but
I will have the privilege yes I have so
much fun collecting the items by myself
in the darkness
[Music]
then we'll get chapter 5 it's gonna pop
up here at home and chapter 5 will be
the scariest of them all it's what I
hear I went to all the trouble of
collecting these free [ __ ] better be
[ __ ] worth it that's right
and anyway like in favor you enjoyed
subscribe if you come up bro a day but I
don't even know how to say you know okay
here we go a room today I'll see you in
there the nether than I've defeated I'm
making him because I lost my I don't
even know anymore
hey Koster profesh
[Music]
yeah
oh you [ __ ] kid got I ain't you hey
yeah yeah the [ __ ] are you Nelly